[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
all right so this this is the xiaomi mi
11 ultra xiaomi's latest and greatest
creation for 2021
with a camera bump the size of the moon
on the back it's a big one so you might
have seen that i posted a picture of
this phone on twitter and i asked just
would you rock a phone like this and the
answers were mostly two things one uh no
just make the rest of the phone thicker
to match the thickness of the camera
bump just add some battery and make it
flush
or two
yeah
if
the camera is actually amazing
all right well that being said let's
just jump straight into this camera
shall we also stay tuned to the end of
this video where i have a trailer for
retro tech season two it's finally ready
and it's dropping daily starting
tomorrow on this channel it's gonna be
lit
but
this is the world's largest smartphone
camera
in more than one way so it's not even
like it's that many cameras by today's
standards anyway it's got three on the
back along with a triple led flash and a
whole touch screen which i'll get to but
each of these cameras on the back of
this thing appears to be a world's
largest in some way so the primary
sensor is the world's largest camera
sensor in a smartphone then the ultra
wide gives you the world's largest field
of view the widest ultra wide of any
i've seen in a smartphone
and the zoom at 120x
is the biggest zoom in any smartphone so
far so right off the bat on paper
pretty impressive so all right the main
camera that ladies and gentlemen is a
one over one point one two inch sensor
that is really close to one inch you
know what else has a one inch sensor
the sony rx100 now of course that also
has a whole real optical zoom lens and
it can do a lot more it's a dedicated
point-and-shoot but to fit nearly the
same size sensor inside a smartphone
is pretty incredible it's kind of hard
to understand how awesome that is so
that 50 megapixel sensor bends down to
12 megapixels has an f 1.95 aperture and
ois now if the question is can this
phone hang with the rx100
the answer is still mostly no because
that glass does make a huge difference
to a photo even if you do have a similar
sensor but that huge sensor does deliver
a certain look and that look is high
detail and shallow depth of field all
the time so literally anytime you have a
close-up subject you can count on the
background being blurred out of focus
none of these shots are portrait mode
this is just straight snapping photos it
absolutely epitomizes that big sensor
look in a smartphone but guess what that
also means if you have even more
close-up subjects like i do you're going
to start to see fringing around the
outsides because the plane of focus is
so thin
that most of the object unless it's flat
is actually going to be slightly out of
focus we've seen this from other big
sensor smartphones i do really like the
processing though i gotta say it's very
naturally sharp it's not like this over
processed hyper sharpened look like i've
seen a lot lately so these are just some
of the photos i've been taking with it
there's plenty of detail and information
and when you zoom in they retain that
detail so that parts really nice aside
from that though the colors aren't
really all that amazing to me the hdr
works well though it does still
occasionally overdo it and the fringing
sometimes gets really annoying when you
have very close up subjects and i take a
lot of those but generally this camera
is quite nice and not looking over
processed until
night time so that huge sensor is
specifically letting in tons of light so
at night you can pretty easily take low
noise photos with a pretty fast shutter
speed some phones just like to make
shots at night look like they were taken
during the day
maybe you're into this look maybe you're
not there's no doubt though about the
light gathering advantage of such a huge
sensor this is the same shot in a one
and a half second exposure from the mi
11 ultra versus a three second exposure
from the iphone 12 pro and same deal
here they're both very detailed photos
and they look very similar but the
xiaomi is a little brighter and more
importantly it took less time than the
other one all right so then
the ultrawide this ultra wide camera
with a 128 degree field of view
so look i've seen a lot of ultrawides on
the back of phones in my day ever since
that lg g5 and i think it's safe to say
this is the
widest ultra wide i've seen yet gives
you the biggest field of view and it has
a lot of the same processing
characteristics as the main camera it's
48 megapixels and it's got the detail
the pretty flat color the hdr but what i
noticed is because it's so incredibly
wide
the outer edges of the frame like near
the corners are much softer and more
distorted than most of the middle so by
the time you crop in from that super
soft corner you end up with a pretty
normal looking ultra ride but it's nice
to have the extra flexibility of a
camera that can just capture everything
in one shot for sure i literally never
had to worry about backing up from a
subject so then lastly your zoom you got
yourself another 48 megapixels at a 5x
optical zoom which can take you up to a
120x
on the digital zoom side which that's
the biggest number that's the furthest
digital zoom you're gonna find today in
a smartphone camera now the usability of
a 120x zoom is very debatable you know
they do the same software trick samsung
does by showing you where you are in the
overall frame when you're zooming in so
you at least have an idea of what you're
looking at but most stuff you shoot past
about 50x just looks not great and the
120x photos just look like a smear of
pixels like a guessing game unless you
know exactly what you're looking at it's
not going to be great i file this
directly into the novelty drawer but
there is no doubt that you can get much
much sharper like 5 to 20x zoom photos
from this camera and they still have
shallow depth of field which is pretty
nuts all three of these cameras will
shoot night mode photos and all three of
these cameras will also shoot 8k video
which is pretty great although 8k video
is locked up to 24 fps so i found myself
shooting in the correct frame rate at 4k
30.
you can also do 4k 60
but pretty impressive on the video front
and you can see the staggered hdr
really working here i feel like i can
see way more into the shadows with this
video camera like in clips like this
you can switch also somewhat smoothly
between all three cameras while shooting
video at 4k which is sweet and i was
impressed with the color consistency
between all three cameras now the
minimum focus distance is not nearly the
same from the telephoto when it kicks in
so if you're shooting something close up
probably don't switch the telephoto but
aside from that whether you like the
color tuning or not they've gotten it
very consistent between all the cameras
it's good stuff but something else i've
noticed with me 11 ultra it seems to be
working
really hard
doing this camera stuff so
it's you know there's a couple features
that are enabled by the snapdragon
triple eight but just because they're
enabled doesn't mean they're
efficient or easy for it so with heavy
camera use i actually noticed two things
one the battery plummeted
look at this graph this is a 5 000
milliamp hour battery going from about
45 percent to near 25
in a couple of minutes and xiaomi
software is just straight up telling me
like yeah it's the camera that's killing
your battery the built-in battery
setting lets you play around with the
graph and look at exactly how much
battery certain apps drain in certain
time periods and the camera was the
culprit here but the other thing i
noticed is shutter lag or at least i
thought it was shutter lag but it's
actually just a lag of the shutter
animation
the photo you're taking
is actually as soon as you touch the
button
but then the animation plays a split
second late so it kind of feels like the
opposite problem the oneplus 9's have
where you think you got the picture but
then you didn't with this camera you
might think you missed it but you
actually did get it so it feels a bit
slow overall but the shots are in fact
very quick if that makes sense so now
you got the world's largest smartphone
sensor the world's largest field of view
ultra wide the deepest zoom in any
smartphone camera
might as well finish it off by making it
the world's largest camera bump
by adding a screen to the back
because why not so i actually had to
think about this i'm not sure if it
actually is the biggest ever camera bump
by volume just because phones like the
lumia 1020 exist but this display on the
back here is pretty funny fun fact it's
actually the same display that's in
xiaomi's me band 5. it's like they
realized they had some extras left over
and just thought hey why don't we put
these in the back of the phone so it's a
1.1 inch ammo led touch screen with a
126 by 294 resolution it's not super
sharp at all i can literally see pixels
and it's also not very bright but
it can show you a couple things it can
show you the time
your battery status and a notification
light if you have any waiting for you
and i can also show you any number of
pre-loaded images with a black
background that's
kind of cool if you just want a cactus
on back your phone all the time but
there's also a whole customizer built
into the software where you can put a
text quote permanently on the back of
your phone or even upload your own
custom image hence the thumbnail for
this video not quite as custom as the
rog phone 5 ultimate but it's up there
but really the only actually useful
thing i've seen it do is act as a tiny
viewfinder for the main camera so you
can take high quality selfies on those
massive sensors you can zoom in and out
and everything and that'll be a much
higher quality selfie than the perfectly
average 20 megapixel selfie camera could
ever manage other than that
honestly not super useful it's pretty
cool of course it's a touch screen but
yeah i think you spend most your time
looking at the front of the phone but
here's what i guess you can say here is
that screen brought the camera bump all
the way to the other side of the phone
here so now you have this big square
camera bump
that doesn't rock side to side on a
table
so i guess if it's between screen and no
screen then
i'll take the screen all day by the way
the rest of this phone is sick it's
called the ultra for a reason this is
xiaomi's absolutely high-end
top-of-the-line flagship and it's got
all the specs and the features to back
it up it's a snapdragon triple eight
like we talked about 12 gigs of ram 256
gigs of fast storage and the 5 000
milliamp hour battery like you talked
about is pretty impressive but not as
impressive as 67 watt wired charging and
67 watt wireless charging on an optional
xiaomi wireless charger i don't have
that specific wireless charger but it's
definitely good that a phone that can
run down your battery like this can also
charge up real quick like this
and so it also has an ultra high end
display as you can see 6.81 inches 1440p
120 hertz oled with an in-screen
fingerprint reader curved edges and a
super bright
1700 nits maximum brightness that makes
it very readable indoors outdoors pretty
much everywhere and honestly it's got
pretty much every other high-end spec
you can actually think of in a phone
like just name a high-end spec in your
head this phone's got it all right great
haptics check
ip68 check reverse wireless charging
yeah check 10 watts it's got an ir
blaster okay great speaker quality oh
double check there's harman kardon dual
stereo speakers on the top and the
bottom and it's all wrapped up in xiaomi
software that i've talked about a little
more in my mi 11 video but that i do
think is also getting really good this
phone does it all short of levitating
but i just do want to land back on that
build one more time
you see the photos and the crazy bump on
the back of the phone and it just looks
like a lot but once you actually start
to use the phone
i found that my finger i naturally like
kind of
rested right underneath the camera sort
of propped it up like that
and i was kind of nice and so i know a
lot of you were saying oh just just make
this phone thicker give it a ten
thousand milliamp hour battery and get
rid of the camera bump
but
this phone is already quite heavy it's a
ceramic back phone first of all and if i
weight it which i did literally up
against some of the other flagships it's
one of the heaviest
and so if you add all of that battery
you lose the grip of the camera and then
it's just one big slick thing like i get
where you're coming from but i feel like
it's surprisingly not too top-heavy with
this current design and i actually don't
mind it so
just something that you get a difference
between seeing the phone and actually
using the phone but hey at the end of
the day it comes down to you would you
rock a phone with a gigantic camera bump
like this
or not for the big time sensor the big
time ultra wide the big time zoom
and the screen on the back
would you be into that let me know in
the comment section below it's probably
going to keep getting more extreme from
here on out okay
retro tech time
it's finally back season two of retro
tech is finally ready for your eyeballs
and it's a little bit different this
time so last time on season one of
retrotech we went through six gadgets
that changed the course of history and
affected everything that came after them
right left a ripple in our universe
things like the walkman and the mac and
the dynatac
this season it's a little different
this time we're exploring some of the
ideas from the past that we thought
would be our future by now
and whether or not we got there so every
day this week starting tomorrow we're
dropping daily new episodes of retro
tech season two it's gonna be so sick
they'll all be at 9am eastern sharp just
like this video was so whatever timezone
you're in write that down you can do the
calculations but come back here at the
same time every day for this week for a
new episode i'll see you there
roll the trailer
i don't know what exactly we're about to
take out the box let's find out together
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
when you think about the future
what comes to mind
[Music]
for decades people dreamed of
technologies that would change the way
we travel
look and live
so have we already reached our retro
futuristic dreams
and if not
what could possibly
lie ahead let's energize
yes my dreams have been realized what is
your experience with hoverboards almost
none okay oh geez oh my god
this season on retrotech
we're doing technology
this is gonna explode if we keep pumping
how does the technology of the past
i got an eye in predict our vision
you're about to see everything for the
future all your particles will disappear
simultaneously and then show up in
another place we need pioneers to see
how this can all come together
[Music]
you